hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over the marshall trap that
comes from the petrov defense that job
finn starts out with pawn to e4 pawn to
e5 Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and in this
variation white captures on e5 black
plays d6 white retreats to f3 a lot of
what I'm going to be showing in the
marshal trap is just one of the common
lines that you will see in the petrel
defense so if you do play black as pitch
off defense
you'll probably be very familiar with
this so if you do see this particular
line come up in the petrel defense that
you're playing you may want to try it
out so we'll go ahead and continue on
with the variation black is now going to
capture on e4 it would have been a
mistake for him to capture right away on
e4 before he played these six he would
end up losing material but he first
plays d6 and then when the night comes
back to f3 black then captures with
Knight to e4 White's going to continue
his development bring his pawn to d4
attacking and trying to control the
center and Black's going to solidify the
center control that he has with his
knight on e4 by bringing his pawn to d5
White's going to continue to add
pressure on this knight on e4 by
bringing his Bishop to d3
black is going to bring his Bishop to d6
putting a lot of pressure on the
kingside it's common theme in the petrol
defenses you'll see to start to build up
a lot of pressure on the kingside which
is exactly what black does in this
particular case from here White's going
to Castle kingside very common Black's
going to Castle kingside as well one of
the things you want to do in any opening
is put your king in safety and since
white or black both don't have any of
their pieces on the DC and B files that
definitely want to make sure the Castle
kingside because it would be at least
four moves before they could castle on
the Queen side from here white plays c4
and this is a move that you'll see very
often trying to break up the center
control that black has and this puts a
lot of pressure on this d5 pawn a lot of
times you'll see a move like pawn to c6
trying to add more pressure on here but
blacks going to avoid that in this
situation and bring his Bishop to g4 and
you'll see this in pretty much any
opening bringing the Bishop to g4 for
black the LightSquared bishop pinning
down this knight here to the queen very
aggressive move from black here and from
here White's going to take the pawn on
d5 since black did not want to hold on
to it y is just going to go ahead and
take this extra pawn that black is
giving up
and from here blacks going to continue
bring his pawn to f5 supporting both of
the pieces on d4 and e4 and here is the
Marshall trap that you'll see and pretty
much any opening but especially in in
this situation it's very tempting for
white to bring his rook to e1 anytime
there's an open file or semi open file
you want to bring your rook there that's
really where your rook is best suited he
can't really move right now the rook on
f1 for white can't move anywhere and he
would really like to have it along this
efile so that he can pretty much reign
havoc on the entire file especially we
like to have it there so we can continue
to add pressure on to this knight on e4
which is really just a pain in the side
for white right now because it's can't
do anything but white really can't do
anything right now to get rid of it so
why would really like to bring his rook
to e1 and add more pressure what white
should do is bring his Knight to c3 put
on pressure put pressure on the knight
on e4 like that but this is a trap so a
trap means that one of the players is
going to be making a mistake and in the
marshal trap the mistake is going to
come from white moving his rook to e1
thinking it's a good development move
bringing his knight to an open file here
but actually it's going to spell doom
for the white from here black has the
great sacrifice of Bishop to h2 check
and then after white cannot capture with
his knight here because again his queen
is pinned down so if you were to capture
this bishop on h2 then black could
simply take this Queen on d1 that's not
going to be very good for white so
instead after the King captures on h2
then black can come to F to capture this
pawn at the same time attacking both the
Queen on d1 and the bishop on d3 the
queen is forced to move here you can't
white can't give up his queen so he's
forced to move this Queen we're going to
put it on e to here and then once black
takes on d3 and white recaptures on d3
now black can capture on f3 safely
doesn't matter if the queen or the pawn
come to g3 and capture we'll go ahead
and do the Queen the black King Queen
can come to h4 attack the King and at
the same time forking this rook on a1
and there's nothing white can do about
it which kind of sucks for white but
this is the marshal attack it comes off
in the petrel defense if you don't play
the petrel defense you're probably not
going to see it if you do play the
petrel defense it really depends on if
you're going to see this line there are
three main lines that you will see in
the petrel defense but if you do come
across this line for those players that
do play it this was one of the most
common lines that you will see so you
actually may come across this line more
than you may think you just may not have
known what it is but now you do so if
you come across it you don't know how to
take advantage and if you're white
you'll know how not to fall into the
trap and you will develop your Knight to
c3 trying to add pressure to the e4
square and not bring your work right
away to the e1 square so hope you guys
enjoy the marshal trap if you haven't
already please subscribe hope you guys
enjoy it I'll see you guys next video
thanks for watching